in January 2023 we are going to begin
the next year year eight of the worlds
of speculative fiction series and I am
soliciting input about which authors to
include we're going to be looking for
three and I'll tell you about how this
is going to work in just a minute to go
into the mix for next year don't comment
yet because there's a lot of things I
need to lay out ahead of time and you
might be suggesting somebody that we've
already done or already plan to do now
if you're wondering what is the worlds
of speculative fiction so this is a
series that we originally started in
person hosted by the Brookfield public
library and we would record the videos
many other people would watch them
worldwide and it's focused on
speculative fiction so you know science
fiction fantasy horror utopian dystopian
alternate history all sorts of other
areas as well and we would have each
session devoted to a narrative Universe
spanning usually several stories or
novels of an author so you know we would
talk about the author and their
biography and what went into the works
we'd also talk about how they were
received and what their influence is
were on them and the influences they
exercised and then we would delve into
the World building this is a really
important part of the narrative universe
that is being
put in front of us and then we talk
about philosophical themes and we have
done this with over 60 at this point in
time and you can see the playlist I'll
link to it below so this has been an
ongoing thing and then when covid hit
obviously we couldn't meet at the
library anymore so it went online and
for you know the last year and a half or
so we've been doing things that way with
a video premiere and live chat and then
a zoom video conferencing session so
people all over the world can
participate in this uh this series as we
do it now every year it's become a
tradition I pick out about nine authors
and book series that we're gonna do and
then we look for suggestions for the
additional three so this is where you're
going to come in
we're looking for people that we haven't
done already and we don't already have
lined up I've actually gotten a lot of
great input over the years about series
that and you know authors and texts that
I probably wouldn't have come across on
my own in in the past just you know
given my own resources so if you've got
suggestions uh you'll want to give them
after you've heard what we've got coming
up and the people who we've already done
so who are the authors and texts and
narrative universes we're doing in 2023
let me give you the rundown in January
we're going to be continuing the
Hyperion cantos looking at the second
part of it with books three and four uh
on in February we're going to be looking
at um uh sapkowski's Witcher series the
first four books there's eight in the
series at this point so we'll look at
those four that was a big fan suggestion
one by the way in March we're going to
be starting with Kim Stanley Robinson's
Mars Trilogy and we'll do part one of
that and then we're in April we're going
to pick up with part two and it's more
than a Trilogy actually though there'll
be four books in this discussion so
that'll span two months in may we return
to CJ chera's Alliance Union Universe
we'll be looking at some more of the
books you know we did her a while back
and I'm a big fan of her work in June we
have another author who we've already
discussed before as well uh Catherine L
Moore's gyro of Jory stories so those
are going to be a lot of fun as well and
then in July
Clark Ashton Smith's weird Tales will
have some representative stuff from him
people have been asking for uh Smith for
a very long time in August we returned
to J.G Ballard and we're going to be
looking at his very early World
environmental apocalypses and then in
September we're going to look at n.k
jemisin's broken World Series so those
are the authors and narrative universes
that we're looking at all the way up to
September
um
October November December that is going
to be up to you and what we're going to
do is solicit a whole bunch of
suggestions and each person should give
a suggestion not not a whole list of
them pick your favorite person that we
haven't done already or we're not
already lined up to do and then
um you know put it into a comment and
we'll take the top four of the comments
create a poll and then you get to vote
and I will turn my attention to those
authors text works narrative universes
that you have selected so we're not
doing the vote yet we're still at the
suggestion phase leave your suggestions
in the comments I do want to run through
very quickly the people who you
shouldn't suggest because we've already
done them so
um here is the list of them J.R Tolkien
a van vot C.S Lewis I Isaac Asimov Frank
Herbert Rogers zelazny Ursula Kayla
green Michael morcock Philip K dick
Mervin Peak George RR Martin Philip Jose
farmer Madeline langel Douglas Adams and
McCaffrey Orson Scott Card Ian Banks H.P
Lovecraft William Gibson C.L Moore
Octavia Butler Jorge Louis Borges Fritz
Liber Robert Heinlein L Sprague to Camp
Andre Norton Arthur Clark Robert Howard
Gene Wolfe CJ chaira Jack Vance Edgar
Allan Poe G.K Chesterton Mary Shelley
Lewis Carroll tanith Lee Piers Anthony
Gordon Dixon August durleth Carl Edward
Wagner Aldos Huxley Braum stoker R Scott
backer Lucy Shin Walter Miller cord
wiener Smith China meowville Mary
Shelley stanisla Lem Neil Stevenson
Philip Stapleton Veronica Roth and J.G
Ballard anybody else that you want to
talk about in the world's or in the
realm rather of speculative fiction
leave is a comment below their fair game
if there's enough comments they'll go
into the hopper for the vote and you
know hopefully you'll see your favorite
authors talked about in this series so I
I'm going to thank you in advance for
giving your input I find it very helpful
and valuable and I look forward to
seeing what it is that you have to say